おそらくハサミ史上最強に危ない必殺技かまいたちの夜
[拍手]
4込じゃあ肇社長ですねっ
[音楽]
あっ自分でもね感心するくらい部屋が汚いんですよ見てくださいこの撮影日や演習部屋
玄関遊び場
[拍手]
本当にあれ捉える部屋がもう今めちゃくちゃ汚いですよバラエティレベルって本当に
バランいないんだとなぜそうなるかというとなんか動画で使ったものとかもねやっぱ
ステッドダメですが結局はね
直下なら動画でたなんか色々使ったものとかそれは開封するときに出ちゃうな箱のゴミ
とかめちゃくちゃ大住ってなかなか捨てられなくてそんな部屋をもう本気で尊重しよう
ということ
のでもう4つで今回は掃除しますのダンスありですよ恭平のあるいただくまあ今日ヘラ
の穴れたりた今日はもう部屋がありとあらゆるものを急いでしてますマジで本当に
捨てる祭してます今日いうわけで今回はどんな形で boku wa のに今あるもの
を全部なるべくゴミに出すとどれぐらい込みが出るのかっていうかちょっと思って検証
してみようと思いますたビビるからね一人暮らしの人間だ
いやじゃないレベルのゴミが出ると思うので今日も1日がんばっかーじゃあ生じてい
ます
うん
詰まっています使いがこここれですつまりますねああいうは彼はそれでお願いします
わかりましたまず不等号捨てたいうどんから前ぐらいのスペ一枚です1万入れ日です
あれちゃいますやれ
のりりんちゃったけど俺今日寝る場所なくなっちゃった
me
ごめんなさい
日
amaran
me
今これやばくないどうすんのこれああ
今回のビフォーアフターについて拓海はこう語る
今回僕が手がけさせていただいたんですけども
ゴミ捨てただけですなんということでしょうあの
米クズのようだったいえば一瞬で新居のように早変わり
足の置き場もなかった腐った玄関も
好き道とような透明感を取り戻す
遊び場だった部屋にも
活気が戻りました
[音楽]
ana
me
teame
ana あっ
がとうございません
まあなのボクんちのゴミ屋敷がひとまず普通のよくなったなって思いました
みんなそうまずはちゃんとするぞじゃなく